um there's nothing quite like a fresh
glass of water but how fresh is water
well believe it or not as much as half
of the water you drink is older than the
sun the universe contained water before
our son was born but for a long time it
was feared that when a star is born
nearby water could be obliterated into
hydrogen and oxygen and the cosmic rays
needed to form plentiful water again
could be blocked by its solar wind only
in rare circumstances like our own could
a sun reform new younger water in its
system after its birth but recent
studies of the water around us and
models of how water forms in the first
place have found that anywhere from 30
to 50 percent of the water in our solar
system the water we drink in bathe in
predates the sun which is embarrassing
for our container technology chemicals
and packaging can leach into water
giving it a bad taste over time so even
though much of this water has been
around longer than our solar system it
expires in just a few years